everything everywhere all at once the
movie that will never make you look at a
bagel or a load of laundry the same
again I'm about to tell you a ton of
stuff you didn't even know that you
didn't know about the biggest movie of
the year
though seriously despite all the
Multiverse Mayhem and mind-blowing CGI
the craziest thing about this movie was
probably the budget our film is an
independent film it's fairly low budget
for the ambition of the script directors
Daniel scheinert and Daniel Kwan only
had 14 million dollars to make this
movie come to life considering the film
made over 104 million dollars at the box
office that's a pretty good payout for a
low budget Indie movie which is totally
what this was a low budget Indie movie
okay maybe medium budget but for a film
with CGI action sequences that could
rival The Avengers 14 mil is practically
a drop in the bucket or maybe even a
drop of detergent in the washing machine
sorry I'm getting ahead of myself really
quick though if you guys want more
awesome behind the scenes footage of
your favorite movies and TV shows
subscribe to this channel so you never
miss a video it's worth it I promise
anyway despite the film's low budget
they managed to hire some serious talent
but did you know that Michelle yo wasn't
originally cast to play the lead
character Evelyn Wong the Daniels
actually envisioned Jackie Chan to play
that role that's right earlier drafts of
the script featured a male protagonist I
can see why they'd want to cast Jackie
Chan because there are so many epic
fight scenes but honestly Michelle did
such a good job with the stunts in
action I'm glad they chose her also just
a fun fact before I move on everything
everywhere actually used real archival
footage of Michelle at the premiere of
crazy Rich Asians talk about meta and
I'll talk more about her in a sec but
first I just gotta tell you about the
effects we ended up having almost 500
visual effects shots well we did that
with mostly just five people usually the
credits for visual effects goes on and
on and on blowing up the budget but this
movie pulled off all these shots with a
super tiny team special effects like
puppets and animatronics and practical
effects like camera tricks and acting
with props were super important to make
this movie as well and by the way did
you know those hot dog hands were
actually real gloves the Practical
effects team made it's so much easier
because you the actors know exactly what
they're reacting to and they can play
like this creative approach to
filmmaking saved the team a ton of money
on CGI we didn't have to have someone
act opposite a tennis ball for the
raccoon the Daniels actually helped a
ton with the special and visual effects
even filming some of the footage
themselves so I actually got just like a
little camera like what like a little
pocket camera and just film streets like
this this shot of New York was just me
going through New York Daniel Kwan
revealed the reason much of the film
takes place in a laundromat in an
interview with Digital Spy he said my
grandfather on my dad's side came from
outside of Hong Kong and like a lot of
the people who moved to New York
Chinatown they started laundromats it is
definitely the personal touches in this
movie that are what make the
over-the-top action scenes so great
that's just one of the many personal
aspects of the film and also why
Michelle was so excited to take on the
role of Evelyn she wanted to act in a
movie that would highlight narratives
often erased in mainstream movies like
immigration hardships queer identity
even the ways mother-daughter
relationships can be indefinitely
complicated almost as complicated as the
Multiverse itself Michelle has been in a
ton of great movies including crazy Rich
Asians but she felt the role of Evelyn
offered a unique and exciting challenge
in both the Thematic content and
practical effects especially on such a
small budget in the end she was perfect
for the role but did you know that
Aquafina was originally going to be cast
as the lead well that is after they
decided not to cast Jackie Chan though
the official reason was never released
it seemed like a scheduling conflict
prevented Aquafina from taking the role
probably because she was shooting two
other films at the time okay and Jackie
Chan might have been an understand
andable casting choice but Daniel
Radcliffe I wonder if the Daniels just
love casting people named Daniel they'd
actually worked with Radcliffe before
too on the movie Swiss army man which if
you haven't seen it yeah it's crazy in
everything everywhere all at once Daniel
Radcliffe was supposed to have a small
cameo in the movie playing inside
Evelyn's laundromat and honestly
Radcliffe was super excited to be in the
film but he ended up having to turn it
down due to scheduling conflicts as well
dang actors sure are busy it's not the
end of the world though Daniel's part
ended up going to Aaron Lazar instead
you might remember him from Wolf of Wall
Street or Avengers end game though this
Cameo was pretty out of the box for
Aaron I think he did a super awesome job
it's honestly so cool a small
independent film like everything
everywhere all at once can have such
huge box office success with a totally
Perfect cast what were your favorite
parts of the movie and be honest would
you want to try on those hot dog finger
gloves let us know what you think in the
comments and be sure to like And
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
things
[Music]